قالت نائبه وزير الدفاع الامريكيه ان
الاوكرانيه عفوا ان مليار ان نتصفه
الدعايه الروسيه بام المعارك في بخمه ليس
نهايه العالم كما اضافتنا الجانب الروسي
يحاول تصوير ضخمه على انها حدث مروع وتقسم
الواقع الى قبل وبعد معارك ضخمه مباشره ان
الدفاع عن ضخمه سيتم طالما كان ذلك ضروريا
من وجهه نظر القياده العسكريه
وشددت مليار انا الدعايه الروسيه ليست هي
من يحدد المده التي سيتم خلالها الدفاع عن
باك موت وفق قولها قال المتحدث باسم
القوات الاوكرانيه في الشرق ان الوضع في
بخموت صعب وديناميكي لكن القوات الروسيه
لم تكتسب اي ميزه استراتيجيه هناك
واضاف ان الروسي يحرزون تقدما تكتيكيا في
ضخمه وان الجانب الاوكراني يعمل على اتخاذ
اجراءات مضاده
في غضون ذلك قال الرئيس الاوكراني كانه
ستكون هناك عواقب وخيمه على اوكرانيا اذا
خسرت معركه باخمر واضاف في مقابله مع
وكاله السوشيت بريس ان الرئيس الروسي
يعتبر سقوط ضخمه نصرا خاصا له وسيبيعه
لشعبه والغرب والصين وجميع البلدان
سيكون انتصارا لبوتين الذي سيبيع هذا
النصر للغرب ولمجتمعه والصين وايران
والبرازيل ودول امريكا اللاتينيه وجميع
البلدان وليس الى
التي تفهم التفاصيل وتشعر بخطوره الامر
لانها تجاور روسيا
مراسلنا حسام مسعود حسان
كيف تفسر تصريحات نائبه وزير الدفاع من
جهه حول باخ موت والرئيس الاوكراني من جهه
اخرى عن هذه المعركه
نعم سلمى هي سلسله من التصريحات التي تشير
الى ان الوضع في ضخمه صعب للغايه وفق
التصريحات الرسميه والواضحه من المسؤولين
الاوكرانيين ولكن بعدد من المسارات يجري
الحديث عن الوضع في ضخمه نبدا من حديث
الرئيس
الذي قال ان خساره باخموت ستكون خساره
سياسيه اكثر من كونها تكتيكيه وان هذه
الخساره في حال تمت ستؤدي الى ضغط ربما
يشعر به من المجتمع من داخل اوكرانيا كما
من خارج اوكرانيا وان الرئيس الروسي سيقوم
بتسويق وبيع هذا النصر
للدول في المجتمع الدولي وكذلك
للصين وايران وفق قوله هذا ياتي في اطار
حديثه عن الوضع هناك وعن هذه المعركه
المستمره منذ اكثر
عن الاوضاع الميدانيه في تلك المنطقه وهذا
الحديث كان بعد زياره قام بها هو الى عدد
من الجبهات من بينها ايضا جبهه بخموت
واقرب النقاط اليها هذا الحديث ايضا اتى
في ظل عدد من ايضا المسارات التي تحدث
عنها الرئيس الاوكراني في هذه المقابله مع
وكاله من بينها تحدث عن التغيرات السياسيه
في الولايات المتحده مثلا وقال ان
الولايات المتحده في حال تغير الحكم فيها
والواقع السياسي ربما يؤثر ذلك على الواقع
الميداني في اوكرانيا وقال ان الولايات
المتحده تعلم انها في حال توقفت عن دعم
اوكرانيا فان اوكرانيا لن تفوز هذه
التصريحات اتت ايضا في سياق تصريحات
لنائبه وزير الدفاع قالت فيها بشكل واضح
ان البروباجندا الروسيه وفق قولها تحاول
ان تظهر ان بخموت هي المعارك وان ام
المعارك بالنسبه لاوكرانيا ليست نهايه
العالم وفق قولها وربما هذا ايضا تهيئ
للمجتمع الاوكراني لكل السيناريوهات
الممكنه هي اكدت ان القوات الاوكرانيه
تقوم بالدفاع عن بخمت وفقا لما لديها من
قدرات وامكانات وانها لا ترتبط ولا تربط
ذلك بالواقع السياسي هذا ايضا اتى بعد
تصريحا للمتحدث باسم قياده عملات الشرق
اكد فيه ان هناك تقدم تكتيكي لكن القوات
الاوكرانيه تقوم باجراءات مضاده لذلك شكرا
لك مراسلنا من كيف حسان مسعود